[MUSIC]
>> Hi.
My name is Savas Parastatidis.
I'm Cortana's architect and
co-founder.
We are here to present Cortana,
who is your personal assistant.
She's been used by about 150
million users today across the
PC, Android, iOS, Xbox and very
soon by a device like this one
what we call the intelligent
speaker at home.
Cortana follows you wherever you
are, and she tries to understand
you so she can provide you with
the best personalized experience
you can get from a personal
assistant.
Cortana reads your e-mails so
she can understand the
commitments that you're making
to others and remind you when
that commitment is due.
She tracks your appointments so
she knows where you need to be
at what time, and she informs
you if there is traffic along
the way to ensure that you are
where you need to be at the
right time.
She allows you to track your
grocery list.
She lets you play music.
She will allow you to stream a
news-related podcast.
In general, Cortana is your
personal assistant helping you
to be productive and go on with
your life, helping you save
time.
You should try and use it on
your PC and on the phone, your
iPhone or Android device.
Thank you.